explain to me why it is more noble to
kill 10,000 men in battle than a dozen
at dinner hey youtubers it's Charlie
welcome to my game of Thrones Season 4
preview for Tywin Lannister the true
king of Westeros and the greatest joy
vampire you will ever meet I dare you to
try and be happy around him just look at
that face I also want to say a big thank
you to you guys for subscribing I'm
getting ready to hit 40 thousand
subscribers and I'm in the middle of a
doctor who give away I'll have
information about that in the
description below on a business so let's
talk about how Tywin's character is
developing in season 4 as well as my top
5 worst Tywin Lannister moments so if
you've never seen any of my game of
thrones previews before or you're
finding me for the first time spoilers
for everything in books 1 through 3 and
minor spoilers for book for the time
when Lannister is one of the greatest
psychopathic narcissists that I've ever
seen in fantasy literature he is a
family man and is capable of human
emotion he did love his dead wife at one
point but his children are really only
pawns to him on the show I'm talking
about Cersei Jamie and Tyrion and on top
of that if it was even possible he cares
about Tyrion even less if he could he
would totally get rid of him but because
he's a Lannister because he carries the
Lannister name he won't kill him in that
final scene with Tyrion and Tywin at the
end of season 3 you really get the sense
that Tywin just wants him to go away
just wants him to be dead so in season
four he is going to get an excuse to get
rid of Tyrion for good because Tyrion
gets caught up in a super spoilery event
during season four Tywin canna sees that
as an opportunity to get rid of him he
doesn't really care if Tyrion is guilty
or not but we don't have any POV
chapters so it's hard to know exactly
what he's thinking but mostly it's just
an excuse to get rid of Tyrion one thing
that will probably change about Tywin
and season four is all the extra scenes
they'll shoot that weren't originally in
the books so Charles dance is an amazing
actor so that's seen in season three at
the end with Tyrion and Tywin was
actually mostly improvised we're going
to get a lot more scenes like that in
season 4 with Tywin and other characters
so any shippers out there holding out
hope for the queen of thorns we might
get to see some more awesome queen of
thorns versus Tywin scenes one of the
great things about a song of ice and
fire and Game of Thrones the show is is
that bullies never ultimately win people
always get their comeuppance
unfortunately a lot of good people get
caught up in that too so there will be
some revenge had upon Tywin eventually
but I don't think it will go down
exactly the way it does in the book so
if you've read the book try not to spoil
too much in the comments
I going to add a bunch of scenes like I
said because Charles dance is just an
amazing actor and they let him improvise
a little bit but now time for my top
five worst Tywin Lannister moments
number five the killing of the last of
the Targaryen or at least he thought the
last of the Targaryen heaven Lannister
was actually responsible for killing
Prince Rhaegar princess Ellie adorned
and their children during Robert's
rebellion the red Viper is elia of Doran
sister and he will be in King's Landing
in season 4 trying to find out who
killed his sister number four letting
the bloody members burn the Riverlands
so during the War of the five kings
after Jamie been captured he ordered the
bloody members also known as the brave
companions also known as lock on the
show to raise the Riverland so they took
up in Harrenhal when you saw those
Harrenhal scenes in season two those
were the bloody members lock is actually
the one that ended up cutting Jamie's
hand off so you can consider that karmic
retribution against Tywin number three
the rains of castamere so this refers to
an event and a song based on that event
when Tywin was young House reyne and how
star Beck formed a rebellion against
their leisured Tywin's father Tywin
responded by killing both of their
families everyone and all their families
and burning their houses down so it was
so infamous that everyone in Westeros
turned it into a song called the rains
of castamere that song is actually used
on the show anytime a Lannister is in
the scene so it actually became the
Lannisters theme song number 2 Tyrians
first wife so Tyrion married a commoner
when he was a teenager he had
self-esteem problems a few more than
most teenagers I imagine so when he fell
in love with someone they got married
instantly after Tywin found out he got
rid of her then lied to Tyrion telling
him that he paid her as a prostitute to
marry him Tyrion swore revenge so in
season 4 he's going to try and get that
revenge and my number one best worst
Tywin Lannister moment the red wedding
though Tywin Lannister is directly
responsible for the red wedding he
convinced Walder Frey to perpetrate the
event in exchange for favor but during
the War of the five kings the Lannisters
in the phrase were enemies but Tywin
Lannister said that if Walder Frey
killed all the Starks and their entire
army that he would basically forgive all
that you can also think of the red
wedding is like a sequel to the rains of
castamere it was also the tune that
started playing when the slaughter
started but let me know in the comments
what are your favourite worst Tywin
Lannister moments and don't forget the
gore continues tonight with the walking
dead i'll be posting that video right
after the episode airs be sure to
subscribe to get it the freaking
governor is back and it's going to get
crazy and as always be sure to let me
which game of thrones character you want
to talk about next right now click here
to get my season 4 preview for Tyrion
and click here to get that new Walking
Dead video thanks so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight high five
you